last night for the first time in
American history we all collectively
laid our eyes on a mug shot of a former
president Donald Trump was officially
arrested at Fulton County jail in
Georgia unlike with the other 900
indictments this time they decided to
take and publish his mug shot now there
was of course no legitimate reason to
take a mug shot of a former president
the whole purpose of a mugshot is to
provide law enforcement with
photographic documentation of the
suspect so that they know what he looks
like and it makes sense that police you
know the jail needs to know that but
Donald Trump happens to be the most
recognizable and famous person in the
world possibly in the history of the
world arguably
when he shows up for trial they aren't
going to you know have to refer back to
his mug shot to make sure it's really
him there's going to be anyone saying
wait is that Donald Trump it's hard to
tell pull up his mug shot
so why did they take this step what was
the point
the point of course was pure humiliation
and vengeance
it was also to give the D.A Fannie
Willis a political trophy to put on her
wall it's something that she wants to
use when she inevitably runs for Senate
or governor in a few years which of
course we all know she's going to do and
that's a big part of the reason why all
this is happening right now
of course it all backfired as it was
always destined to the mugshot instantly
became an iconic image and uh in all the
ways that the left doesn't want it to be
an iconic image and had exactly exactly
the effect that any half-conscious
political Observer knew it would have
which is rallying the base around Trump
is now fundraising off of the image and
smartly so and will likely raise many
millions of dollars just from the mug
shot alone he already has raised
Millions
in fact we could say that if Donald
Trump does manage to get elected to the
presidency again Fannie Willis will be
largely responsible for it she is the
most effective campaign manager Trump
has ever had even if unintentionally
but even if this all obviously works to
Trump's advantage that doesn't make it
any less outrageous or infuriating
nor should we be distracted from the
lessons that this moment is trying to
teach us the most obvious one is that
the left is they are Beyond caring about
even the pretense of legitimacy
something they used to pretend to care
deeply about
in fact through this whole ordeal
they're not even acting like they've
stopped some grave threat to democracy
because they know they've done the exact
opposite of that they are just wielding
raw political power for the sole Lawless
purpose of incarcerating someone who
stands a very real chance of winning the
presidential election in a little over a
year and that's all this is and they're
not even pretending otherwise now in
fact many on the left don't want Trump
incarcerated they want him killed they
want him dead this happened last night
watch
just a few minutes ago Donald Trump the
disgraced ex-president the front-runner
for the Republican nominee for president
four times indicted departed his golf
club in Bedminster New Jersey he's on
route to Fulton County Georgia via
Newark Airport we believe he will
surrender himself for processing at an
overcrowded jail with a reputation for
violence and neglect a jail that is
accustomed to holding defendants facing
charges up to and including violent
crimes where stabbings are frequent and
actually three people have lost their
lives over the last month
that jail
is where the disgraced ex-president of
these United States is heading right now
she can't contain her glees she really
can't she's so excited she's like she's
she's openly laughing about people
getting shanked in jail as she
fantasizes about maybe that will happen
to the former president we've played a
lot of demented Clips on this show over
the years that one is way up there
not long ago Nicole Wallace was running
comms for the White House during the
Iraq War and back then she had to
pretend to care about the deaths of
innocent people at the hands of
establishment Washington until that
happens these people will do everything
they can to silence Donald Trump MSNBC
and CNN after obsessively covering
Trump's trip to Georgia all day
made a point of cutting away from his
remarks uh when he was leaving yesterday
watch
regular people's lives are destroyed
just by the charge
just by the charge just the mere foul
helium
keep going Ben so what we're just going
to be monitoring his reports
you can begin to understand how some
people they don't have a lot of exposure
to the system other people because of
the code they live in and the
circumstances of Life they're exposed to
it a lot those lights that are there
which was not the sort of thing that you
usually see on an airplane airport
tarmac we did think that this is a
possibility tonight we didn't know for
sure that it was going to happen but it
looks like Trump may decide to make
public remarks before he gets back on
his big private plane and flies back to
New Jersey uh if he does that we're not
going to take those remarks live but we
will cover them for their newsworthiness
as we've said in the past there is a
cost to us as a news organization of
knowingly broadcasting untrue things and
given his previous remarks on the
subject that we are almost sure he will
speak on
um we will not carry those remarks live
and you can be mad at us about it we can
take it we're big but we'll cover it for
newsworthiness and we'll turn it around
and let you know what he says after he
has made those remarks you know later on
they say in that clip that they'll get
sued if they air the remark to the
former president after his indictment
and if that was in fact remotely
accurate then any self-respecting
journalist would air the remarks anyway
they'd fight any consequence for it in
court
if the first amendment protects anything
it's airing the words of a former
president at a time like this
but msnbc's statement isn't true of
course it's a dumb jab at Fox News over
the Dominion lawsuit and protects their
viewers from hearing about the substance
in these indictments or lack thereof and
that's why they do it
here's what they're not telling viewers
at MSNBC speaking of newsworthy things
The Fulton County D.A Fanny Willis has
indicted Donald Trump along with 18
co-defendants for the following crimes
offering legal advice to the president
tweeting things that Fannie Willis
doesn't like and in one particular
particularly egregious case of getting
someone's phone number
quoting from the indictment quote honor
about the 21st day of November 20 2020
Mark Randall Meadows sent a text message
to United States Representative Scott
Perry from Pennsylvania and stated can
you send me the number for the speaker
and leader of PA legislature podis wants
to chat with them
this was an overt act in furtherance of
the conspiracy
now think about what a remarkable
paragraph that is Mark Meadows in his
capacity as Chief of Staff to Donald
Trump
was seeking to obtain the phone number
of some politicians in Pennsylvania he
asked for a phone number
and because the reason for that request
was investigating potential voter fraud
Fannie Willis says Mark Meadows needs to
go to prison they're going to send him
to prison for asking for a phone number
along with more than a dozen other Trump
advisors one of those advisors is John
Eastman what's his offense well he uh
Advanced the legal theory that
alternative slates of electors could be
seated if election fraud was found
and that's apparently criminal now which
is interesting because it wasn't illegal
in 1960 when JFK's electors from Hawaii
met secretly and submitted their own
certificates to Washington saying that
he had won the state
as political reported quote the Hawaii
Democrats use virtually the same
language that Trump electors in five
states used in their effort to upend the
2020 race quote unquote
ultimately Kennedy's electors turned out
to be the legitimate ones after a recall
determined Kennedy had won the state
now anyone looking at that episode of
1960 would say it's a good thing that
alternative electors can be sent to
Washington in the case of a recount that
actually changes the result of the
election but now that's criminal
apparently it's a Reco violation
supposedly
John Eastman and several other lawyers
are now facing several years in prison
because they did exactly what JFK's
electors did and were Vindicated for
doing in 1960.
David Shaffer was one of Trump's
alternate electors from Georgia has also
been indicted
Ray Smith is facing jail time too and
what was his offense well per axios
quote
uh he quote gathered witnesses to
testify in hearings before Georgia
lawmakers in December 2020 about alleged
problems with the state's election
that's not allowed anymore I mean
they're just like looking into it to see
if something happened they're trying to
investigate
and that's a crime somehow
also a crime is apparently tweeting
about hearings while they're happening
quoting from the indictment quote on or
about the third day of December 2020
Donald John Trump caused to be tweeted
from the Twitter account at
realdonaldtrumps uh quote Georgia
hearings now on oannn amazing
this was an overt act and further into
the conspiracy
so for the crime of tweeting about a
hearing about election fraud and related
offenses Fannie Willis wants to send
Trump and 18 of his associates to prison
for tweeting and just saying that the
hey this this uh hearing's on right now
it's amazing
that's a crime that's a felony
before giving our dog rough greens he
was so sad and lazy and now he actually
enjoys his squeaky toys and playing
Fetch with this frisbee our pups days
are filled with laughter exercise and
endless fun naturopathic Dr Dennis black
the founder of rough grains is focused
on improving the health of every dog in
America little did I know before I got
rough greens dog food is dead food
everybody knows that nutrition isn't
Brown it's green let rough greens boost
your dog's food back to life Rock raids
is a supplement that contains all the
necessary vitamins minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food you just sprinkle rough Greens on
their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough greens
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath Boost energy levels and so much
more we are what we eat and that goes
for dogs too naturopathic Dr Dennis
black is so confident rough greens will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jumpstart trial bag
so your dog can try it a free jumpstart
trial bag can be at your door in just a
few business days go to roughgreens.com
Matt or call 844 rough 700 that's
ruffgreens.com Matt or call 840 4 rough
700 today
and not only does she want to send him
to prison she wants to do it very
quickly Willis just filed a request with
the court for this trial to take place
in just two months beginning on October
23rd so for this unprecedented criminal
trial of 19 defendants including a
former president based on a completely
novel and insane legal Theory
she wants the defense to have a total of
two months to prepare
is that constitutional
well no one in the DA's office seems to
care
and it's at this point that it's it's
fair to look into the Fulton County D.A
if any Wills uh and and see what she's
all about because it's long been known
that she's a Democrat and she's an
opponent of Donald Trump and in itself
that's not necessarily disqualifying
everyone even DA's have a right to their
own political opinions but
Fanny Willis has gone far beyond that
just a year ago she hosted a fundraiser
for a Democratic candidate running
against one of the targets of her
election investigation was a state
senator named Bert Jones was one of
Trump's alternate electors and here's
how the judge responded when he found
out about this fundraiser watch
using the title of your office
social media that you as this political
office holder are holding a fundraiser
for the opponent of someone that this
political office is investigating
um
I don't know that it's an actual
conflict but
um I use that phrase what were you
thinking where the prosecutor thought I
could prosecute the co-defendant of
someone I defended
it's a what are you thinking moment the
Optics
are horrific if you are trying to have
the public believe that this is a
non-partisan driven by the facts
and I'm not here to critique decisions
the decision was made but if we are
trying to maintain confidence that this
investigation is pursuing facts in a
non-partisan sense no matter who the
district attorney is we follow the
evidence where it goes and ignore the
fact that I hosted a fundraiser for the
political opponent of someone I've just
named the target
so this is a judge that's not exactly
using an iron fist here well you know
it's uh it's probably not appropriate I
don't know you're investigating someone
and you you go to a fundraiser uh you
host a fundraiser for the political
opponent of a person that you're invest
actively investigating I'm not saying
it's a conflict but uh jeez you know
maybe you don't want to do that next
time
so the judge is a coward uh but the
point is that this is a D.A who has to
be told by a judge not to host
fundraisers for the political opponents
of politicians she plans to prosecute
she's that dumb and corrupt
by the way Jones ultimately was not
indicted along with the other 19
defendants probably because Fannie
Willis knew the judge would throw it out
she blew that prosecution but if you
look at Fannie Wilson's social media
feeds as Benny Johnson conservative
commentator uh did the other day then
you'll come to the conclusion that she
actually she's blown all 19 of these
prosecutions
Willis's feet is littered with posts
casting doubt on the legitimacy of the
2020 election before the vote total
suddenly shifted against Trump quote
Georgia could determine who is our next
president she wrote on November 4th 2020
a team of lawyers needs to watch them
count every single vote they can start
in Fulton where we are having water
leaks what ballots are they throwing out
Georgia let's Georgia let's give an
honest accounting no stunts
again this is the D.A now Prosecuting
Trump for questioning the legitimacy of
the election in Georgia
and she was questioning its legitimacy
in 2018 Willis said that it was
suspicious that local election
Commissioners hadn't approved a recount
of some votes in Fulton County quote you
all better start paying attention to
what's really going on she also argued
that the Secretary of State quote
controls elections adding quote I wonder
if we yet realize that is an important
role she also posted a lot of BLM
propaganda of course she worships
Camilla Harris she owns a mug saying
she's a proud Democrat
so we can conclude that Fannie Willis is
something of a politically motivated
election denier
as always the left is guilty of doing
exactly what they accuse their opponents
of doing
the obvious point is that Donald Trump's
social media posts if they're criminal
then so are Fannie wells's social media
posts if he can go to jail for tweeting
stuff uh questioning elections then she
should be in jail right beside him
her prosecution of Donald Trump based on
her posts is an overt act in furtherance
of her conspiracy to keep Donald Trump
out of the White House
now will Republicans indict Fannie
Willis
if Republicans retake the federal
government will they jail her for
election interference
well you ask any conservative right now
and they'll tell you that that'll never
happen
and they're probably right
we're seeing a vast difference in
tactics right now let's say between the
two major political parties
conservatives would never dream of doing
any of this they would never dream of
dragging say George Soros into court on
some pretexts you know for the sole
purpose of harassing him liberals on the
other hand have no problem suing Elon
Musk for not hiring enough refugees
they relish every opportunity to use
state power to punish their opponents
Republicans on the other hand don't have
the the backbone for it they don't have
the backbone to play this kind of game
to Fight Fire with Fire they never have
they're not doing it now
and that just means that with each
passing month the left is getting more
comfortable
they're being getting more comfortable
being the only ones
who are fighting this way
first they target grandmothers walking
around the capitol then they jail
Douglas Mackey for some memes
then they go after Donald Trump for his
tweets and his quote unquote classified
documents
and now in Georgia they're targeting not
only Donald Trump but more than a dozen
of his advisors and Associates
this will continue
until Trump and all his associates are
in jail or all their opponents are
after this latest indictment it's time
to stop pretending otherwise
if you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
Walsh Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed